(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are tackling the question
what is our relationship
with gross foods?
- Oh we have a relationship
That's news to me.
- I don't know if you
know but we also have
an audio visual program that
comes out five days a week
called Good Mythical Morning.
Oh man, we've done, I've kinda traced
our relationship with
good through the episodes
of the show--
- Like Shabaz.
- What?
Oh, not like Shabaz, but
you should tell people
what you mean by that.
- Whenever I hear the word trace,
this is--
- That's awesome.
- Just absolutely--
- I know what you're
talking about.
- Ingrained in my brain.
Shabaz moved to Buies Creek, what grade?
- Probably seventh grade, maybe--
- Uh--
- Definitely eighth grade
he was there because at
the eighth grade parties,
the eighth grade party,
Adam Nicholson's house.
- I was gonna say fifth but okay.
- Yeah he could have been there earlier
but I know that he was in our friend group
in eighth grade because he
would come to the parties.
- But Shabaz,
all of a sudden, when you're that age,
it's like the ability to
draw is like a social,
you got points, everybody
knows the kids who could draw.
You know what I'm saying,
it's like being able to draw,
it's like oh yeah, Mark,
he's a really good drawer.
- In grade school there's an expectation
that everyone should draw and then sadly--
- But some people are actually good at it.
- That's weaned out of
people but then by the time
you get to later middle school,
which I think is where
this story takes place
or this memory, there's just
a few people who continue
to draw, like Kevin Wins,
he continued to draw.
- I think he continues to draw.
- He's good at drawing.
- But anyway Shabaz was
breaking out these incredible
renditions of like Warner
Brothers characters
and comic book characters
and bringing them to school
and we're like, what, this
new guy is incredible.
And I don't know who discovered
it but Shabaz was tracing.
- It got out.
- The secret got out.
- It got out
that he was tracing.
- It was basically plagiarism.
It's visual plagiarism.
- These had much more of
an impact on you than me.
I think he must have been
in your class, not mine.
- [Rhett] I don't know
man, I think I, because--
- [Link] When you hear the word trace--
- I was so intimidated, I'm intimidated
by people who are better at things than me
and I'm like well I can draw too.
And so I was just mad at him.
You know like when Shay
Mitchell was so great
at tasting--
- I think, yeah.
- Very similar.
- Yeah, that came out of me, an anger
that was then validated when I found out
that she was tracing so to speak,
she was given the freakin' answers.
- But yeah that's what,
when I hear tracing,
I think of Shabaz.
I will always--
- When you hear
the word tracing.
- The word tracing.
That was quite an aside.
- When I hear the word Tracy,
I think of Tracy.
- Yeah me too.
- Who we went to high school with
and she had an older boyfriend
who was a real cowboy.
- Shane?
- No, he had like a crew cut and he was--
- Blonde hair.
- He was a real cowboy.
- Yeah he had like a--
- He had boots
and he used 'em.
- Right and had the belt
buckle, tucked his shirt in.
- Yeah.
- What's his name?
- She was in my typing class
and I kinda flirted with her
but I wasn't her type 'cause I didn't--
- Was that a joke?
- No it wasn't.
(Rhett laughs)
I didn't even know I said it.
Are you intimidated by
how well I can throw puns
out there without even knowing.
Does that make you angry?
- Yeah makes me feel like
you're tracing, you're
tracing your comedy.
- So I've traced how we got to the point
in Good Mythical Morning
where we consume so much food.
We do, I have to believe we
have a different relationship
with food because of the way
we eat so much gross stuff
and just food in general.
- Without a doubt.
- So I'll come back to that,
there was some fascinating
things in that timeline
that surprised me at
least when I Shabazed it,
so we can come back to that.
- I like that, that's a good usage.
- Also I have some interesting tidbits
about what makes things that
are typically not tasty,
something that you might
acquire a taste for
like the psychology behind what I'll call
acquiring a taste for something especially
when it comes to hot
peppers and gross things
and it extends beyond just foods as well,
so I'm prepared if it
comes to it to also talk
about that because in my
mind that's what led up to,
that was a starting point
for this conversation
and also Alex asking us
how has our relationship
with food changed because of the show?
I was like that's a good
question, we'll talk about that.
- Okay, but first we wanna
just catch up on the fact
that we are both about
to head out of town.
Obviously we're gonna be in,
at the time of recording this,
we'll be in London next week for VidCon,
doing our VidCon appearance
and also our show, our concert.
- That was weird how
you said it, at the time
of recording this, we will
not be in London, we're here.
We're recording it right now.
- I corrected myself, at
the time of recording,
we will be in London next week.
That's how I completed my sentence.
- As of right now when we're speaking,
once we're done recording this podcast,
we're both leaving on
independent vacations
and then right on the backside of that,
we're going to London.
By the time you listen
to this, we'll back back
from all of that and then
you can expect, I guess--
- If it's worthy of a podcast.
- We'll probably give you,
each other and you an update
on our vacations but I mean, I'm in like,
have I forgotten something important,
like a passport or are my
underwears clean type of thing?
What are the main things
that I need 'cause--
- It's a short trip though, short trip.
- I'm just taking a
long weekend to Mexico.
I'm going to Cabo because
you've already been
and I thought that was a good idea.
I'm not taking my kids.
- Do you need the watermelon outfit?
- Well I still have it.
- 'Cause I don't need it where I'm going.
- I should take it to Cabo.
I was thinking about when
I took that for Instagram,
Christy was like, you should
wait 'til we go to Cabo,
I was like, I gotta come back now.
I gotta do it here and it was raining.
It was kinda like a
polar opposite situation.
- Little bit, which interestingly
is kinda what's happening
with our mini vacations
here because the place
that I'm going, I looked
at the weather last night
and it was currently
one degree Fahrenheit.
One degree Fahrenheit.
- What, okay.
- That's 31 below zero Fahrenheit.
It's Mammoth.
- It's not, again, it's
not 31 degrees below zero.
- 31 below freezing.
- Freezing.
- Fahrenheit.
I'm going up to Mammoth, interestingly.
- Have you been there?
- Yeah went last year.
- So it's a ski mountain, I've never been.
This is your second time.
- I think it's the largest
ski resort in California.
It's definitely the highest elevation
so it gets the most snow
and they just got 10 feet
over the past weekend.
10 feet, that's a basketball goal.
- That's crazy.
That is nuts, man.
- It was a blizzard.
It was nuts.
- Are you gonna be able
to get there, I mean--
- I'm a little nervous--
- You're leaving basically hours from now,
first thing in the morning.
- Well I mean,
everything is hours from now,
it's just a matter of how many.
- Well, aren't you philosophical?
- All things in the
future are hours from now.
- Listen if you keep talking that smack,
I'm not gonna let you borrow
my rooftop cargo carrier.
- I'm not taking it, I don't need it.
- Oh so that's why.
- Well because Locke sprained his ankle.
He's not skiing.
Jessie had already made a
decision that she was not
going to ski and that she was
just gonna chill and read.
- Okay.
- And so that leaves me and
Shep and so the only right now
I need the rooftop
carrier is to get the skis
back and forth from where we rented them
because we're staying at a
place where we can just walk out
and then walk to the lift.
- Well isn't that special.
- So I believe that the--
- Hey, if you don't want my carrier,
you don't have to have it.
- I mean I'll take it.
I'll take it if you want me to.
- It's not like I didn't
get the best carrier based
on Amazon reviews in existence--
- I'm worried about--
- Largest capacity.
- The gas mileage.
- Hey you know what.
It's not like it's the most
aerodynamic rooftop carrier
that exists.
- Well you haven't driven, so,
halfway--
- You don't have to borrow it.
I'll just keep it at home.
- Halfway to Mammoth.
- My feelings aren't hurt.
- When you get to the southern
end of the Sierra Nevadas,
the wind is ridiculous, like I'm afraid
that the rooftop carrier, I'd just end up
on the side of the road sideways.
(clicks tongue) Right off the side.
But the main reason, I just don't need it,
'cause Shepherd's got short
skis, I got long skis.
It'll be in there for a half an hour.
- I'm not taking it personally.
- But I'm gonna be freezing,
you're gonna be living it up.
I'm gonna be freezing.
- Yeah, no sprained ankles.
No children at all.
- I am excited about skiing.
And hopefully I'll have
some kind of story,
not too harrowing.
Because one of the things I read was,
there's something on the Mammoth website
that was like, you know,
beware of something something something,
basically falling into
deep snow and suffocating.
- Oh.
- There's a term for that.
- 10 feet of snow, that could easily--
- 'Cause you know how it is,
the one time that we went
with Eric--
- Yeah.
- I guess it was--
- Park City.
- Park City and it was,
it's like a blizzard while
we were on the mountain.
- If you go off the groomed or the paths,
he was trying to take us
through little shortcuts.
- But if you really don't
know how to ski well--
- And that's crazy, it's like--
- You just fall under the powder.
- And then you cannot get out.
- There's an art to staying
on top of the powder.
I like the groomed, man.
- It's like Legolas.
- I'm a blue man.
- You gotta be like Legolas
in Lord of the Rings.
- I'm like Blue Man Group on the slopes.
I see the blue and I go for it.
I stay away from the black diamonds.
I don't like the slopes,
I like the gentle paths
through the trees.
- You like percussion
on found items.
- Yeah, yeah yeah yeah.
- [Link] That's really
what you're talking about.
- And I have a show in Vegas.
It's just me going through the trees.
- I thought about taking
Jade with Christy and I
on our pre-Valentine's romantic weekend
in Cabo before I head
away to actually be apart
from my wife and the love of my life
when Valentine proper hits.
I'll be entertaining
Mythical Beasts in London,
which by the way, if
you wanna come see us,
go to RhettAndLinkLive.com to
see where we're gonna show up
at a place near you.
Around the U.S. we have
some other dates posted
and we're doing music.
We're doing a bonafide concert.
There is costuming involved
at a certain point.
- Right and we continue to announce dates
as those things fall into
place and I'll just go ahead
and do some more plugging
while we're at it.
If you're a member of
the Mythical Society,
you actually are the first to find out
about where we're playing so
you can get those tickets,
get the good seats, get the VIP tix,
that kinda thing, that goes
to the Mythical Society first.
- So I'm trying to figure
out if I should take Jade
as a last minute decision just because,
the answer's no.
I just mentioned it to
Christy, I wasn't like,
I wanna bring Jade,
this is about me and you
and I do understand that so
I didn't say any of that.
All I said was, well you
know the hotel allows dogs.
I just left it at that, and she was like,
I know but we don't need to bring Jade
because this is about us
and I was like exactly.
- Yeah right, I'm just like,
you know, it's just a fact.
- To me--
- I'm letting you know
other peoples' dogs will be there.
Just in case you wanna
bring your dog repellent.
- I just think it's a fun
idea to fly with a dog,
to bring a dog to another hotel and like--
- Why is that a fun idea?
I mean you have an unusually--
- You see what she does.
- You have an unusually easy dog.
- She could be here right
now and you wouldn't know it.
- But even though she's so easy--
- She's like a fanny
pack without the strap.
- But she's still a little--
- She sits there on my body.
- But she's still a burden
because she wants your attention.
- Yeah that's true.
Again, I don't wanna do
it, I want it just to be me
and Christy and--
- Well you haven't had
the dog at the pool with you?
- That would be kinda cool.
- No.
- Being that guy.
Be like Dr. Evil or something having the,
my cat with me at all times.
- Well yeah--
- I haven't seen those movies but I think
that's what happens in 'em.
- I think you're talking
about Inspector Gadget's
arch nemesis.
Maybe Dr. Evil has a cat, I
can't remember, I'm bad at--
- He does have a cat.
- Remembering details.
- I haven't seen it but
I think he has a cat.
So anyway, so far we're gonna move
onto everything we've already talked about
but just in summary,
we've devoted this podcast
that you're listening
to to what might happen
in other podcasts that
we'll tell you about.
- That's interesting.
- That's what we've
done so far.
- Wow.
- We just, we basically
teased other episodes
that we don't even know
will exist, it's like,
this is what's gonna happen in our lives.
If there's something to report,
best believe that this is the venue
that it will be reported.
- That's tantalizing.
- As well as, I probably will
have posted lots of stuff
on my Instagram, shout out to
me on Instagram, LinkLamont.
- Oh you can do that now, that's good.
- I'm really gaining momentum over there.
- Mm-hmm, yeah you're on quite a pace.
- But you know what,
I'm just dancing like no one's watching.
So let's get to that
food stuff in a minute.
- But first we do wanna let
you know that you can procure
the sweater or sweatshirt that I have on
and the baseball shirt
that Link is wearing.
- Now yours just looks
like a black long-sleeved
spin sweatshirt--
- Especially,
especially in the dim lighting.
- Let's do that, kinda reveal that, ooh.
There's a little surprise in there
and it's the Mythical logo.
- It's very, very cool.
You have the Mythical logo as well.
- I do.
Go to Mythical.store and
get all types of stuff.
All types of surprises.
Rep us, connect with other
Mythical Beasts out there
in the wild when they see.
- I thought it was rep your boys.
- Rep your boys.
- Yeah, we should get that website too.
- Do irreparable damage.
- Oh gosh.
- By reppin' ya boys.
Mythical.store.
- Okay I'm interested to talk about,
'cause I'm emotional.
Speaking of food, I've got
some almonds that are still
in my throat.
- In the back?
- Some salt and vinegar,
which interestingly enough,
the reason I like the salt and vinegar
is because they bite you a little bit.
They give you a little bit of a bite.
You know that you're eating them.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, there is a mouth punch.
- But this has come up--
- That possibly a child,
if they were to eat
one, would be repulsed.
- They would not like it.
A child does not typically
like salt and vinegar
unless they have acquired that taste.
- This is what I'm gonna get into.
You want me to start there
or where do you wanna start?
- Well I was going to say
that this is a question
that I feel like I get, I'm
sure you get it as well,
from just anytime I'm eating with someone
who is a friend or at least knows that
enough about our show to know
that we eat weird stuff on our show.
I feel like there's just this expectation
that, well, yeah sure, order
that because Rhett's here,
because he's known for eating anything.
- Mm.
- Has that happened to you?
While I'm eating with
people at restaurants,
there are conversations about my
gastro exploits, that's one word.
- I think it's very clear
that I don't like a lot
of the things that I consume on the show
so I don't run into things like, oh,
we can order that because--
- Usually it's--
- Link will like.
- We can't order that because Link's here.
That's a different saying.
- Somebody was having a conversation
and it was like, some
weird combination of foods,
they're like, oh, that's something to try.
You know what, wouldn't
it be fun to try that
and then they realize
they were talking to me
and were like, oh, I'm sorry,
that's kind of your job.
(chuckles)
- Right.
- Maybe it was Britton
at the house, like we
were just hanging out.
He caught himself.
I can't remember who it was honestly.
I erased it from my memory 'cause it was,
I wasn't in work mode.
But yeah, I do think
there's this, oh yeah,
even with friends and whenever any of
that weird food stuff comes up,
the conversation takes
a different complexion
because I feel like
somehow we found ourselves
in a position of being
the guys who eat stuff
on the internet.
- That is a facet, that
is a facet, that is not me
as a whole person.
- So let's come back
to that but let's start
more with the psychology
and the science and
this other podcast that,
I was looking for new
podcasts, like browsing,
seeing what I could listen to.
- You listened to all
of our Ear Biscuits back
so many times that you just
couldn't take it anymore.
You had to get something else.
- I found a podcast called Hidden Brain,
it's an NPR podcast.
I'll try to remember to
tweet out a link to it
but you can search anywhere
podcasts are found,
not a sponsor it's just explorations
in what happens in the brain
and how that impacts our daily lives.
I've only listened to one episode
and it's an episode called
Radio Replay, I guess that
it means it was on NPR
and then they put it on the podcast,
again at a later date.
Yum and Yuck.
- Repurposing.
- Yum and Yuck is the
actual name of the episode
and I highly recommend listening to it.
It's very entertaining, but I was like,
they're gonna talk about
eating nasty stuff.
I wanna see what their take on this is,
and there's some psychology studies
and there's this guy, the guest they had
on there has done studies
and one in particular is
about how, well,
he was talking about
people eating hot peppers
and he went to a
particular town in Mexico,
I believe I'm remembering this correctly,
and he was kind of
exploring the subject there
where, in this particular place,
they treat hot chili peppers
like I treat salt and pepper,
mostly pepper, like I will
douse something in pepper.
I just like it, I like the black specs,
it adds a pop of contrast
and then it adds a pop
of not spiciness but a
different type of pepper
in my mouth but chili pepper's
a totally different thing.
I mean there is pain associated
with eating a chili pepper.
And everybody eats them
in mass quantities,
like it's like it's not a
choice, it's just understood
and thoroughly enjoyed by everyone.
Once you reach the age
of five years old, okay?
Sometimes as early as two so
like two to five years old,
they start to like chili peppers.
Now before that, you can't give a baby
or an unacclimated four
year old a chili pepper
and they're gonna like it,
that's just not gonna happen
but from across the
board as a true statement
by five years old they're
all eating the chili peppers.
He was trying to figure out why
and he started looking at--
- Now, just to clarify--
- Yeah?
- I would assume that
this is much of Mexico
that this applies to, he's
just studying this town.
- Well he happened to be in this one town
and that's what I was
getting at, what he did was,
there's dogs and pigs around
that are eating the food
that's thrown out which
is laced in chili peppers.
So his question was, have
they acquired a taste
and an enjoyment of chili peppers as well,
so he put out a cracker
with some hot sauce on it
and then a cracker without it
to see which one random dogs
and pigs would prefer.
And, what's your guess?
- My guess is that they
did not prefer the spicy.
- Correct, they did not prefer the spicy.
Now they ended up eating
both of them because
they're animals and they're hungry
and they're gonna eat both.
- Right, eat anything.
- But they preferred the
ones that weren't spicy.
They just tolerated, whereas,
humans do something different,
once they get to that age
of five years old or so,
they're actually starting to prefer it.
Now, the first reason was described
as societal and social pressure,
I mean you're all
gathered around for a meal
and all the older people, older siblings,
they're all eating the chili peppers
and even though it's a painful
tear-jerking experience--
- And that's not something
that would apply to dogs.
- It's something that these--
- Peer pressure is not a
thing in the canine world.
I mean probably in some way it is,
but not with eating hot stuff.
- Right so you know it's not
actually an acquired taste,
like the more you eat, then
you start to prefer it.
But in humans, they start to prefer it,
if given the option of putting
the chili peppers on it,
they will do that.
They won't go so to speak to the cracker
that doesn't have it.
- Yeah.
- So what's the difference
there, what's happening?
So the societal pressure to
overcome the initial pain
kind of breaks the seal
and you start eating the chili
peppers but then the dogs
and the pigs inform us to say,
well, even once you eat it,
it's still not an acquired taste,
there's something else going on.
- Well okay so let me at this point,
before you get into the what is going on.
- Mm-hmm.
- I'm gonna give you
just my layman's,
I'm not trying to guess
where the science is going,
I'm just gonna say,
as someone who likes hot
stuff, or liked hot stuff,
okay 'cause something changed with me.
And also someone who has--
- Interesting.
- And also someone who has a son who,
Locke was eating hot wings
as early as I could remember.
When he could have, and
it was not me telling him,
son, you should eat this,
'cause Shepherd still
doesn't like hot stuff.
Shepherd, less than two
years ago still described
toothpaste as spicy so,
this is different palate.
- Yeah, Lando calls LaCroix spicy water.
- Right so--
- Just 'cause it's fizzy.
- But Locke enjoyed hot
wings and would get like...
He's 14 now and back when we were living
in Sherman Oaks and he was
like seven, eight, nine.
So even younger than Shepherd,
we would go and get hot wings.
- I remember that.
- We used to get Zaxby's
back in North Carolina.
- Yeah.
- So anyway.
- Which had different levels of hot
and he would get something
on the hotter side.
- He would go very, very
hot and then, of course,
once he got to be like 10 or
11, he would go all the way
to where I would go which
I think is like nuclear
or something like that at Zaxby's.
I stopped eating that stuff
because over the past couple years,
something's happened where it affects
my stomach way too much.
I don't care about burning
mouth, I love the feel
and the taste, but the way
it's affecting my insides
and my skin, I have like
breakouts and stuff.
Anyway, too much detail.
- Too much detail, Rhett.
- But--
- You're veering off.
- To me,
I always just thought, A,
I would have said that it
had more flavor, right,
so I would have said that
the spicy has more flavor,
which, I believe is a indisputable fact
when it comes to a hot wing.
Like when you get mild at a place,
it just tastes like butter,
you know what I'm saying,
if you get mild buffalo.
- Butter is a flavor, I
mean I'm just gonna say,
it is a different experience.
But I wouldn't, I mean,
I just wouldn't say
that it doesn't have
flavor, it just doesn't--
- It doesn't have as
much flavor of the type
of flavor that I'm going for, but then,
it does get into this place that like,
there's an experience of eating,
eating the hot wings is like something,
it's memorable, it's super
active if you're doing it
with somebody, you're talking about it.
It makes much more out of the meal
so you end up just
thinking, I like hot stuff.
- It adds a fun element.
- Right, it's fun to eat hot stuff.
- Well, and that may be
baked into the answer
that I learned from the Hidden Brain.
Which they then began to
describe something that,
a phrase coined as benign masochism.
Which is enjoying initially
negative experiences
that the body, slash brain,
falsely interprets as threatening.
So it's something...
It's experiencing pain from something
that is not actually going to inflict
real damage, it's
something that's thrilling
but not actually threatening,
so that experience of
knowing that it hurts
but that you're totally
gonna be fine fuels the brain
and creates an experience that
you want to continue to have.
- Well it's like if
you're like in an accident
and then you walk away
from it, there's a thrill.
That's like an extreme
example of that but--
- Well a better example
is a rollercoaster.
- We've talked about
rollercoasters before.
We didn't use that term benign masochism
but that's why I said,
when I don't get sick
on a rollercoaster,
the reason I love it is
because I feel like I'm
simulating near death
without being anywhere close to it.
- Right.
Also for things like coffee.
It's like the initial taste
of coffee is very bitter,
it's not something you
would like, and again--
- But that's an interesting--
- I've always talked about
an acquired taste but--
- That's an interesting
extrapolation though.
So the guy is saying that--
- On a brain,
on an inner brain, psychological level,
that's something that's happening.
Now he didn't actually
talk about acquired taste
because that would have
been my explanation.
That's like, the more you
eat, the more you like it,
but again, the pigs and the dogs don't.
There's something else going on.
- So we got into this a little bit
when we talked about pickiness right?
I find this interesting
because you can rattle off
a lot of things that are
traditionally thought
of as not good, blue cheese, right.
Blue cheese is a prime
example of something
that is very polarizing.
- I don't like it.
- And it tastes like
rotten cheese because
essentially that's what it is.
And I absolutely love it
right, it's just this bite
and I love it.
But when it comes to rollercoasters,
we're both just as willing
to ride a rollercoaster.
It's not like you're afraid
to ride rollercoasters,
but you don't like blue
cheese, you don't like olives.
Spicy mustard or
whatever, super hot stuff.
- I think...
I don't think olives is
really, and pickiness,
it kinda goes a little too
broad because I think--
- Licorice.
Licorice.
- Okay.
- You know what I'm saying.
Things that have this weird--
- I don't experience pain
associated with licorice but
I also don't experience pain
associated with the bitterness of coffee
which they did talk
about so I guess, okay.
Yeah, licorice.
It's something that on a
deeply instinctual level,
it's like oh my gosh, this
shouldn't go into my mouth
because it's going to,
your brain's saying--
- Poison.
- From an evolutionary
standpoint, it's gonna contaminate you.
- 'Cause it's bitter like
poison, 'cause the thing is is,
just as somebody who enjoys--
- But once you know it's not--
- But somebody who enjoys
licorice, black licorice,
and the saltiest, I have some
of that salmiaki in my office,
probably still saying that wrong.
It's not like when I eat it
I'm tasting strawberries.
It's not like when I'm eating
it I'm tasting something
that's like sweet and good.
I'm tasting something
something that tastes like
I'm biting into a root that
I pulled out of the ground.
The bitterness for me,
this is why I think,
it is all in the brain.
- You're relating to this is what--
- 'Cause I think that
when I taste licorice,
I'm essentially tasting the,
now everybody's taste buds are different.
I understand that,
there's different amounts
and different sensitivities
and there are super tasters et cetera,
but I don't think that, it's just like,
people are like how do
you know that I see green
and you see what your green and the lyric
from the Thoughtful Guy, why do you know
that we see self colors in the same way?
Well because we have no reason to believe
that we see colors differently
because the same DNA,
the same genes that contribute
to your visual apparatus
are the same kinda genes
that contribute to mine,
so red is red, right?
- Okay so you're saying
most people taste licorice,
they taste the same thing.
- I think you taste
licorice the same as me
but your brain has a
different perspective on it.
And it must be this masochism thing.
- Benign masochism is
not a rational thing.
I think it's a subconscious
thing that's happening.
- Clearly, yeah.
- But can you start
to pull from that subconscious
when you're eating
the licorice, can you filter
that experience through,
I don't know, dying?
- No but I think I can
pull it into like smelling,
like smelling a fart.
- Okay.
- You know sometimes you
fart and you smell it
and you're like that's
horrible but you're like,
I gotta keep smelling it. (laughs)
- Just take it in.
- Yeah, I think that,
you know who you are.
You know who's done that.
- Suck it all up.
- Not somebody else's fart.
I've never savored someone else's fart.
Let me just be very clear about that.
- You savor your own.
- Not all mine,
just sometimes.
- I feel like maybe
you're learning something.
Maybe your subconscious
is learning something.
I think Jade smells,
she smells her own poop.
- Well dog--
- And I think she is learning.
- Dogs have this.
- She's definitely learning
something--
- Dogs like to roll in trash.
- [Link] About her own health.
- Dogs like to eat trash.
- Well that's different.
That's more of like a camoflaugey thing
but smelling your own poop, not eating it,
but smelling it, some dogs eat it.
They talk about that in the podcast too.
I think she's learning
something about her own health.
Kinda like sending your fecal sample off
to some sort of doctor.
- Which incidentally I
think I've shared this,
I have the fecal sample kit at my home.
Ready to be filled up.
- Oh well let me not help you with that.
- I will be telling you
all about it when I do it.
- Why?
- 'Cause I went to
a new doctor and I said
I want the full run-down.
I want everything, I want
blood work, he's like,
you want a fecal sample thing?
- What?
- Well of course, if that's an option.
- That sounds fun, what?
Of course I want that.
You just wanna be thorough
'cause you're a hypochondriac.
- I want a full evaluation.
And I kinda like the idea
of being in my bathroom
and putting my poop into something
and shipping it to somebody.
- Go to this doctor, he's very thorough.
He's very thorough.
- I asked him, I was like,
can I go outside to do this?
Now I'm gonna be in the front yard.
- What?
- 'Cause man, you know as well as anybody
that open air human feces
is one of the worst things
in the world, it's worse than bear.
- Worse than bear.
So I think the question is,
are we benign masochists?
Are you buying it as far
as, I don't think I am
in normal life, like I just,
I've acquired the taste
of coffee, I acquire, and I'm
still gonna use that phrase,
acquired the taste, in college.
It was very late for me.
- And me as well.
- Oh yeah?
- I tasted it when,
my mom let me drink her coffee.
I have a vivid memory
of tasting her coffee
when we lived in Thousand
Oaks so I would have been,
it's before I met you so I
would have been like five,
four or five.
And being like whoa, and
it's like the first time
your parents let you have a
little swig of wine, you know.
- Or when we...
We're not proponents of
this but we told the story
of trying chewing tobacco, which is--
- Oh that's a prime example.
- Easily one of the worst things
that you can try to put in your mouth,
and the fact that people do it habitually,
I mean, well it's addictive
because there's nicotine.
- But you like that too, I mean that--
- I did not like it, it was horrible.
- You liked it and hated
it at the same time, man.
- But the reason why
was because it was a--
- Social pressure?
- It was illegal.
It was stupid, and it was wrong.
It was forbidden, it was forbidden.
- But you have to admit--
- So I think that's a form
of benign masochism.
- That was something,
while you were sitting
out on one of those rocks
in the middle of the Cape Fear
River and it was super hot
and we were sitting there
spitting into the water.
- Yeah makes you a little
delirious and that feels weird
and like whoa this is
a different experience.
- We're not proponents of
that, you shouldn't do it.
It's a horrible,
horrible idea.
- Do not do it.
- Horrible idea.
- My stomach turns just
thinking about it right now
but I think it's a different
form of benign masochism
that's like I'm motivated
by another factor
which is I know this isn't
gonna, well, long term,
it will kill you but short term,
it's not going to kill me
right now but it feels illicit.
- So I relate to this--
- It's a rollercoaster thing.
- But I do not, when I
think about the things
that we've done on the show,
this is not the same thing for me.
But I think maybe because we
go so far into the extreme,
like if you take
surstromming as an example,
you know, the fermented
Swedish whatever it is,
some kind of fish.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely horrible, the
kinda thing that when we open it
in the studio, everyone has to evacuate.
You don't have to eat it, you
just have to get close to it.
- We didn't even attempt to taste it,
but if we opened it
now, I bet you we would.
And I think that's what I wanna get at.
- But I wouldn't enjoy it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it because it's
the spirit of our show is
to try things and, but I'm
not trying it thinking,
you know what, I might like this,
even that's kind of the unspoken premise
or sometimes the spoken premise
of our show is Will It whatever is like,
is this gonna be unexpectedly
good but I don't go
into those situations
thinking the way that I think
about like okay sushi is an example.
We didn't grow up eating sushi.
A lot of people our age
didn't grow up eating sushi
but especially where we're from.
So the first time I ever
had sushi, it was weird.
The wasabi was a completely new taste,
the eating ginger was, all
that was completely new
and exotic and I didn't
really like it the first time
and then kinda liked it the second time
and then third, fourth
time I was in and now,
I can actually find
myself craving it, right?
But--
- And I think that--
- I just don't see what we do.
- I don't know if that's benign masochism.
I do think that there is
acquiring a taste for something
through another means
that isn't the pleasure
of feeling like you're
going to harm yourself
but you're not.
I think there are other routes
to changing your mind
over time about something.
But I would like to look
back, I kinda, like I said,
I traced Good Mythical Morning,
how did we get to a point
where we started eating so much food?
And, it's interesting that it hasn't,
what you said is that
there's not a component
of it that we actually enjoyed.
We don't actually enjoy in
the moment eating this stuff
that we're gagging,
that's why we gag it out.
But--
- I enjoy every
other aspect of it.
- So don't feel sorry for us.
- Don't feel sorry.
- Don't make comments
where you say things like,
if you guys don't enjoy it, don't do it.
- We enjoy--
- Most people do enjoy
watching us not enjoy it so. (chuckles)
- And we enjoy--
- We gon' keep doing it.
- We enjoy our audience enjoying
that we're not enjoying it
and that makes us enjoy it.
- And when I watch those
montages of us trying
to get things down and not being able to,
I mean, you've seen the
that I react in the moment
when you can't get something down, I mean,
it brings me joy.
(Link chuckles)
There is pure joy in
watching your best friend
not be able to get food down.
That's great, there's
a lot of joy in that.
- I was surprised at how
we got to this point,
so, perhaps there's a digression.
I just wanted to take us
down memory lane because
I always tend to think
of Will It as, you know,
we did an episode called Will It Taco.
(Rhett gags)
(crew laughs)
We did that episode on
Cinco de Mayo of 2014.
- Okay.
Almost five years ago.
- And I went back and
I watched part of that.
Used hard shells, we just put stuff in it.
Broccoli and cheese.
I made a comment on that episode
before we ate pork blood,
congealed pork blood in little
cube, long cube logs of it,
I said, "This is why
we're on the internet.
"This is our destiny."
Like I said that.
- You're a prophet.
- Which is really, really stupid.
I shouldn't have said
that but I tend to think
that that's the moment
where this thing started
to careen into crazy.
That was season five, episode 82.
So I went all the way
back to the beginning,
it's like when did we
really start eating stuff?
Season one episode five
we did Best Candy Bar Ever
and then maybe a month or two
later we did Best Cereal Ever.
We were trying different best evers
and we were doing toys
and all types of stuff.
It didn't catch, so even
though very early on,
we did eat some stuff and rank it,
which we came full circle on that.
- Right.
- We abandoned it.
That's all we did, those
two things in season one.
Season one episode 76 was the next time
I could find us eating something.
They discontinued Twinkies
and we said we acquired one
and I had never eaten a Twinkie.
- How old was that Twinkie?
- The last Twinkie on earth.
It was a fresh Twinkie but
the company was gonna go over.
It was rescued and Twinkie still exists.
- Or go under even.
- Yeah.
It's the only thing we ate in season two.
Season three episode
29, I was playing a game
with you about ways to extend your life
and every time you got a question right,
I let you take a bite out
of a quadruple Whopper.
- Oh man.
- Just 'cause I thought
that would be funny.
- We had the good ideas
back then didn't we?
- Well we didn't know what
was happening, I mean--
- I just wanted to eat
a quadruple Whopper.
- And you loved it.
- Oh yeah.
- You were eating this, you
would get a question right,
you would just chomp on
this quadruple Whopper
and it was a great thumbnail too.
Of course, that didn't
really click into place.
The only other thing
we ate in season three,
there's an episode called
Rhett and Link Eat Insects.
And I think that was,
I didn't watch that one
but I think it's probably
like fans sending us
crickets in a bag or something.
I honestly didn't watch it.
That's the only thing
we ate in season three,
then we made The Mythical
Show and then we came back
in season four--
- No food on
The Mythical Show.
- Not that I recall.
- Interesting that we had not yet--
- Understood--
- That definitely shows
that we didn't understand the potential
that there was in eating on camera,
the fact that we created this show
that we had such high hopes
for and didn't eat a thing.
- Now.
- Maybe we did.
- Now Will It Taco again was season five
but I'm just starting season four.
Everything that I could
find in the cursory search
that we ate, I'm sure
there's a little bit more
but not a whole lot.
We did a thing called the
Habanero Pepper Challenge.
I think that's where we ate
increasingly hot peppers,
getting up to the habanero.
That's before Hot Ones existed.
We did that once, then
we did something called
The Nooodle Showdown in season four
where we ranked different
types of noodles,
like in a tournament style.
Then we never did that again.
It's so fascinating to
me that we did this,
why would we wanna taste noodles?
- Oh, at that point we were really,
we were already trying to figure out--
- We were out of ideas.
- What to do, yeah.
- We got that pill, the
taste tripping pill.
- Yeah.
- Where it makes sweet things
sour and sour things sweet
'cause we were big on experiments.
Like that's how we thought of our show.
We're not really eating
things, we only eat things
if it's part of an experiment
or for inventing something
'cause we invented the Big Mac and cheese
and putting orange chicken on a sub.
- That seems more recent.
- No, season four.
- Season four?
- Then we ate the ghost
pepper to follow up
with the habanero challenge,
we did a ghost pepper episode.
And then we did one called
The Strangest Candy on Earth.
We just got international
candies and we just tasted them
and talked about it.
I mean out of all those
episodes of season four,
those are all the ones
that are food-based.
That's it.
That's all I could find.
Season five, we started
to get going a little bit.
We tasted fake bacon.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then a few episodes later
we did an exotic meat taste test
and then we started putting
sriracha on stuff and eating it.
We got some of that cat
poof coffee and tried that.
I said cat poof but it was cat poop.
- Yeah it made it sound better.
- We did a blind berry taste
test with Strawburry17.
Again, this is an exhaustive list,
this is not just highlights.
These are the only food things we did.
Then we did Bug War which
was me eating a scorpion.
- Oh wow.
That got a lot of clicks.
- Season five, episode 57.
That's like, became our
most-viewed video of all time
because it was a thumbnail
of me holding up a scorpion
and I actually ate the
whole frickin' thing.
- Golly.
- But you see what got us
to that point is, oh we ate
some bugs the previous season,
we ate some exotic meats.
Then we did a pizza taste.
We just did that out of nowhere.
I mean, I'm sure Buzzfeed
was doing their stuff too
and there was a lot of
feeling like we're getting
on each other's bandwagon or something.
That was starting to happen.
- I don't know if we were,
you think we were on the radar
at that point, that season?
Maybe, I don't know.
- Season five is when GMM
started taking off I think.
We ate 40 year old ham and eggs
and then we did Will It Taco.
Then after that, in season five,
we only did two more food
episodes I could find
after Will It Taco.
We did Flying Waffle, which
was Unidentified Flying Waffle,
we tried to invent other
dishes like we did Big Mac
and cheese the last season
and that didn't work so we abandoned that.
And then we did the
Squeezable Food Taste Test
where we fired food at each other's faces.
- Oh yeah yeah.
- Which was a lot of fun
but that was just a weird
one-off 'cause we were doing
a bunch of experiment stuff and again,
we didn't really think
of it as a food thing.
That's all we did.
The next season, we did
Will It Ice Cream Sandwich
because in our I'm On Vacation video,
we played guys who worked in
an ice cream sandwich factory.
And so we came up with that idea in order
to promote people
watching our music video.
And we were like, oh we did
Will It Taco many months earlier
so May of 2014, let's see.
June, okay.
It was only a month later.
- No it was early, it was
maybe in the beginning
of season six.
- Yeah so we followed that up.
And then all of a sudden we
started to do some stuff.
But again, I can quickly
tell you everything we did
in season six that was food.
Smell Tasting, Will It Double Awesome,
that wasn't food actually.
Will It Deep Fry and then
we did the Carolina Reaper.
Did you know that has 25 million views?
- Yeah that's 'cause a bunch of people--
- Crazy, man.
- Keep watching it.
- September of 2014.
- Even now.
- Guess That Exotic Sausage.
We did that four episodes later.
Then we opened the
surstromming with Pewdiepie
in a Good Mythical More.
Did Will It Cereal, started
doing a bunch of other Will Its,
three episodes later we did
Blind Fast Food Burger Challenge.
That's when we started
gettin' in the blindfolded
identifying stuff.
And we started, you see the slippery slope
of us starting to eat more
exotic or weird foods.
It was interesting in my
mind that Will It Taco
did not click in our minds
that we were immediately
gonna start doing Will Its.
Like we do one every month
now but that took a long time
to get going 'cause the
third one we did was
Will It Double Awesome.
'Cause we started doing experiments
about giving yourself
hiccups so we would start
to drink a whole bunch of hot sauce.
We just started to
become much more willing
to put things down our
throats in order to experiment
and find stuff out.
Maybe that's not the best way to put it.
- Well okay so what we were doing,
just to put it bluntly, is we were...
Without even really knowing
or acknowledging at the time,
we were doing, it was kind
of our personal version
of what has happened with
the media, with online media.
- Mm-hmm.
- In general.
So--
- We became these daredevils
and we didn't even know it was happening.
- Well specifically
what I'm saying is that,
okay so, now the news, the
way that the news works
is it's based on advertising, right?
So I mean, I'm not saying anything
that you don't already
know but basically a lot
of people are sort of saying
that journalism is ultimately dead
if something doesn't change
because ads are what is
fueling the journalism industry
and so what do you need?
You need eyeballs.
Truth is not important,
eyeballs are important.
So therefore you're going
to title your article
in a way that gets people to click
and you're probably gonna
be willing to do something
that's misleading, right.
Now we weren't doing, we
were always concerned about
making sure that when
you clicked on something,
it wasn't misleading so it's not the same.
- So we had to actually
put it in our mouths.
We can't dangle a scorpion
and then not eat it.
- The news industry has
been completely transformed
because they want people to click.
Our lives because we were the ones
personally putting ourselves
into this situation.
- Our GI tract.
- Has been--
- Has been transformed.
- In fact we were talking
the other day about
what is the, and this is why
I'm getting my poop analyzed.
And you should too.
- I should too.
- I'm getting my
microbiome analyzed because
I wanna know what's in it, man.
And I think it's going to
be drastically different
than it would have been
before all this stuff happened
because of the stuff that
we put in our bodies.
(Link chuckles)
But that's what we were
doing, we were responding
to a trend and when we
go back and we would look
at a season and we would decide,
what are we gonna do again,
like well, one of the factors was,
well these things got views.
People seem to care about this
so we gotta keep doing those things.
- And we're good at it, we
instinctively know how to
contextualize experimental or weird
or gross foods and also,
and then on the back side of that,
somehow we became
the every man who can say if
I eat a burger blindfolded,
can I tell you what it is or not?
Just because it's just
interesting to people
and we're like okay, but I just wonder if,
like Johnny Knoxville or the Jackass crew,
do they have, is there
actual masochism going on
with them or are they, like
if we were to talk to them,
would they be in a similar place?
I've listened to a few
Johnny Knoxville interviews.
I think I like the guy.
I'd like to meet him, I'd like to ask him
but I don't remember
gleaning that knowledge.
I just get a sense that are
they just doing it for the,
for their version of clicks or adulation
or entertainment value?
Do they actually enjoy it?
There's such a thing as a masochist.
- I think that, first of all,
they're in a completely different league.
- Well yes.
- With what they're willing
to do to themselves.
- Absolutely.
- In fact, the lengths
that they go to are things
that the average Good
Mythical Morning viewer
would probably be uncomfortable with
and there's probably not
an incredible crossover
between the two audiences.
Even though we put ourselves
under duress all the time.
- Well the Coyote--
- It isn't nearly
to that degree.
- And I think I've said before
that I cannot watch Coyote
Peterson get stung or bit
or gnawed upon.
- And I think that that's--
- I could not watch it.
- Have you watched Jackass?
- Not much, no.
- Would you?
Same thing apply?
Like seeing somebody get hit in the nuts
or stuff that, seeing
somebody get attacked
by a lion while in a zebra costume,
I mean they do, that's the
kinda thing that they do.
- I mean I also don't watch other people,
I've only watched other
people watch hot peppers
because they wanted to watch them.
Of course I don't really
watch a lot of stuff.
But I don't watch people
eat gross things either.
The thing that we've
arrived at when it comes
to eating gross foods, the
only point of reference
that I personally have
are the few episodes
of Fear Factor that
happened to be on television
way back in the day where
they would force them
to eat nasty stuff as
a physical challenge.
- Well that's really the first, yeah,
I think in terms of U.S. culture,
that's sort of our first exposure
to that whole phenomenon.
- It's interesting that it's something
that we just had these
couple of weird ideas
and only because they worked
it evolved into this thing.
We weren't emulating anybody
and we weren't entertained
by anybody else doing anything comparable.
Yet we found ourselves in this position
and now you're wondering, has
it impacted your inner biome?
- Well 'cause--
- How else do you think
it's impacted us?
- 'Cause I also don't eat,
it's changed the way
that I eat in general.
Because I feel like well,
when we make the show,
I eat basically whatever I want.
And you know me, if we're
doing a pizza taste test
or whatever, I'm like a cow, man.
I just--
- I look over there--
- I'll just eat the whole piece
without thinking about it.
- I'll have a handful of
whatever it is we're eating,
I look over at you and it's gone.
- Yeah and it's not a conscious thing.
- Did you throw it away?
- I'm a big man.
I'm a big man, I'm a hungry man.
I run hungry.
There's such a thing as running hungry.
- Like your idle?
- My level of hunger is--
- [Link] Like your car idle.
- Even though you're the
one who's always like,
when's lunch?
I'm actually the one who's hungry.
(both laugh)
I just, I'm always
hungry and so I just eat,
but I thought, I'm putting
these things in my body
when we make the show so
I probably shouldn't put
these things in my body when
we're not making the show
so I try not to eat fried stuff.
I try to limit my meat intake.
- I remember talking
to Harley.
- A lot.
- And he was talking about
how he eats healthily
when he's not doing Epic Meal Time,
at the height of Epic Meal
Time we had this discussion
and he was like--
- Yeah you have to.
- We went out to dinner
with him, he was like,
yeah can I get a salad?
I'm kinda gonna eat like a healthy choice
'cause I do that 'cause I'm human.
- Yeah 'cause we went to
that place next to VidCon
in Anaheim that was like
burgers and hot dogs
or whatever, he was like,
I'm gonna get salad.
- Right.
- So it's definitely impacted
the way that I see food.
- But hot foods, I've been scarred.
I absolutely have.
There's no chance of me
getting on that bandwagon
because I been rurnt.
My brain has changed because of the
experience that we have
with the Carolina Reaper
and the Trinidad Moruga scorpion.
So that ship has sailed,
that ain't happening.
- 'Cause what happens with
you is you can smell it
or taste it and it makes
you sick or whatever.
That doesn't happen to
me, what happens to me is,
it was just so unpleasant, especially,
I'm the one who suffered the
most from the Trinidad thing.
I was out of commission last time.
- You were on the show
but then that night,
I was in just as bad of peril.
- We both threw up.
But to me, it's just--
- We both forced ourselves
to throw up so that
we wouldn't have to pass
it the other direction.
- At this point.
- That was not an easy thing
to do 'cause it was just as hot
when you threw it up.
It's not like when it got in your stomach,
it started to lose its hotness.
- Well okay and so a
lot of people have said,
okay well now there's the
pepper X which is hotter
than anything that we've eaten.
Why don't you guys eat the pepper X?
Well interesting.
There's a reason for that, because--
- I don't want to.
That's my reason.
- Well I think it's actually,
there's variables involved.
Right, there's what is the level of pain
that we would go through?
And then what is the reward?
And then how much does the
reward impact where we're at?
So at this point, thankfully,
we don't need to have a video
that gets 20 million views
in order to be okay.
You know what I'm saying,
we've gotten to a place
where we have a product that people like
and we don't have to do,
we don't have to put ourselves
through that much pain
in order to get noticed and
so it's just not worth it
and also, it wouldn't get that many views
because people have seen people
do all kinds of stuff now.
It's not nearly as novel as it was.
You know what, the pain
that we would experience
is the constant.
In fact, it's probably actually increased
because we've gotten older.
So the amount of discomfort
that we would go through
is an all-time high and then the reward is
at an all-time low and that
is why we are not going
to ever eat the pepper X.
You don't need to keep asking us to do it.
We're not gonna do it, we don't have to,
so we're not going to.
- But eating gross stuff,
yes, and fist.
You've never done this,
let's do a fist bump.
- Yeah okay.
- It's good, Rhett.
We'll put our--
- I'm glad you said bump
after that.
- Put a stake in the ground.
- Yeah.
- We put a fist bump together.
But when it comes to gross foods,
I think I have learned, well,
we've learned a couple things.
My brain, I've developed some skills.
I'm really good with a blindfold.
I can operate with a blindfold
in lots of environments.
- You wear it all the time now.
- Put that in my--
- Sleep with one.
- My want ad.
Good with blindfold.
Call me.
- What do you want?
- Well I'm really, I think
we're both really good
at tasting things that have no business
having the flavor they have
and guessing what it is.
Like blindly guessing
incongruous flavors on things
'cause that's happened
a lot over episodes.
- We've got a lot of experience.
- Like just blindly guessing
why something has a flavor
that it shouldn't have.
But then also just the skill to be able
to participate in one of
the most intimate acts
that a human could participate in
and that's consuming something.
- Wow, that's intimate, huh?
- I mean--
- Going inside you.
- I mean it really is, I
mean, if you wanna get down
to what's happening,
I think the reason why it's so compelling
what we and the other people
who eat weird stuff do is
because I mean, the most
intimate thing you can do
with something is put it
in your mouth, I mean.
(chuckles) It's one of
the most intimate things.
- I mean it might be the most intimate.
- Yeah so it's like, if that's gross
and you're willing to consume
it or try to consume it,
that is a feat and we have gotten good
at being able to do that.
Like being able to, I
mean, the amount of time
that we would hem and haw
before we would actually
put something in our mouths
has drastically decreased.
Like we're almost nonchalant about it now.
Like we forget--
- Well and also--
- But we're good at it.
- In going back to
the whole, the variable is,
gross stuff, it's gross for a second.
It doesn't, I mean some stuff
sticks with you a little bit.
- Even if you swallow
it, it kinda disappears.
- Even in the worst case,
you can get the taste out of your mouth.
You can get a taste out of your mouth.
You can't necessarily get
that burn out of your mouth
in the same way, or that
burn out of your belly.
- Right so I think continuing
to eat gross things,
I think we've reached, I hope
Josh isn't listening to this.
- Yeah don't tell him about this.
- I think we've reached
practically the ceiling
of how actually gross something can be.
- But we're not any, I
don't know about that.
I mean I don't feel like I'm any better.
For instance, I've said this repeatedly.
The congealed blood,
ironically the first thing
that we ate that kinda
started this whole train.
- This is the answer to the
question what is the worst thing
you've ever eaten.
- I think it's gotta
be the blood because--
- It's so visceral.
- The reason I don't
like liver, that reason has multiplied by,
exponentially with the blood
because it's got this metallic,
it just--
- I know, but--
- Instantly coats my mouth and
I have this visceral reaction
and it immediately makes me gag.
- I've seen you, without
pause or discussion,
just bite into a heart like an apple.
- That wasn't a problem.
- Yeah.
That's still problem for me.
Like anything that is an in tact thing,
that's nasty.
I have a real hard time
with that, like an eyeball
or like an entire organ.
Like a kidney or a heart,
those type of things.
But I have gotten a lot better.
I've grown as a performer.
It's just a weird type of performance.
It's just, I mean, I'm so
fascinated that we careened,
I don't know, it didn't happen that fast.
That's not the right verb but as I,
how did it make you feel when I tracked
through the ideas that we had?
Does it make you feel--
- Proud, is that what you're--
- I guess.
- You need to feel some
more pride? (chuckles)
- No, no. (chuckles)
- I'm not surprised by it at all.
- It's so weird, right?
- Yeah but at the same
time, I kinda feel like,
and I think this has been
proven when we've initiated
sort of the unofficial initiation,
at least it was at a certain
time for new crew members
with having to eat something.
If you go back and look at those things
or when we've had like
a special guest like
a Make A Wish guest or when
we had the Golden Tee winner.
- Megan.
She, they all ate stuff
like without issue.
I don't think that we're
especially good at it, at eating,
I think we're especially
good at reacting to it.
I think that the thing that
we do that's compelling
is the way that we engage
with it but I don't think it's
that we have some incredible
tolerance for gross things
and I think Josh would show us up.
- Oh yeah.
- He can eat anything.
The dude likes the blood.
He prefers the blood.
- Well we've got an idea.
We're flirting with an idea.
I'll just give you guys
a scoop 'cause hey,
you've listened this
far into an Ear Biscuit.
Talking about what if we
revisited some Will Its,
and I think this was an idea
that some Mythical
Beasts suggested as well
so we are listening, we
hear and we consider that.
I think Stevie might
have seen some comments.
- Well because now we'll be able to do in
in a way that back in the day it was,
throw broccoli into a taco
but now we've got Josh
and he can actually make
something that's interesting,
unique, and innovative in some way so
I think if we revisited things,
it would be in a completely fresh way.
- Can he make some of the
things that didn't Will?
- I think his greatest
challenge is can he make me
enjoy the blood?
- Oh gosh.
- That's really, but I
do wanna just quickly,
'cause I found some
stuff that I think is...
Helps to explain how we're gonna map out
the next years of our life
and how we're gonna relate
to these things because
the good news is, Link,
we're gonna get better.
You think we're already pretty good
at eating the stuff, well
science is on our side.
We are going to get better
because our taste is going
to get worse.
- Oh.
What you got?
- Okay.
First of all, I did not understand this
but okay so basically
taste sensitive cells
are called gustatory cells.
Gustatory cells, it's like
the name Gus and then tatory.
Gustatory cells.
- Sure.
- They're clustered within
the taste buds of the tongue,
the roof of the mouth and
the lining of the throat.
What, you can taste with your throat?
Yes.
- I didn't know that.
- Did you know that you can taste
with the roof of your mouth.
You should take your finger,
put it on the roof of your
mouth and see if you taste it.
- Let's make this an episode.
This will be like a season four episode.
- Good idea.
- Can you taste with just your throat?
- Most people have around between 2,000
and 10,000 taste buds,
that's quite a discrepancy,
quite a range but 9,000 is a
number I got somewhere else.
- Okay.
- So 9,000,
I think it's closer to
10,000 for most people.
Now, your taste buds will
begin to decrease in number
and also shrink and get less effective,
the ones that remain get crappier.
This happens between the
ages of 40 and 50 for women
and 50 to 60 for men,
it happens later for men
so we've actually, the 50
to 60 and then after 60,
those are gonna be the golden
years of tasting for us.
- So a 45 year old man has more taste
than a 45 year old woman.
- On average.
- I didn't say it.
- After 60, many people lose
the ability to distinguish
between sweet, salty,
sour and bitter foods.
So now you're getting to
a place where Grandpa,
it's just like the time that--
- Mush.
- My grandfather-in-law,
my brother-in-law was eating some steak
and he got some gristle
and he couldn't chew it
and so he took it and
he put it on his plate
and then my grandfather-in-law
just picked it up and ate it.
- Ew!
- Because old men
cannot distinguish between
somebody else's spit out gristle
and steak.
- That's texture, man.
That is just, he's also a performer.
- I don't know if he knew
that it had been spit out.
He just picked it off his plate.
And then it gets worse, after 70,
your sense of smell begins to decrease.
Which is just adding to the fact
that you've got all
these dying taste buds,
now you can't even smell
which is 80% of taste
and then what people start
doing is they start adding
salt and sugar so they
could taste more which is
in turn bad for their health.
- Oh.
- I think what this all means is
that people are just not meant
to live that long, you know?
- I think--
- Modern medicine,
we're supposed to die,
we're supposed to be about dead right now.
That's, humans are supposed
to be, what 40, 45, 50.
Like the cave men and then
you're supposed to expire
but we've got all these
modern conveniences
and we can just live forever.
- But not taste.
- We can't hear, we can't
see, we can't taste,
we can't smell.
But that's a great time to
just really lean into this.
- Yeah I think what it means is--
- So after 70, man.
- Boy, we're really gonna
turn a corner on Good Mythical Morning.
- We'll just be eating,
we'll be eating the testicles
right off of animals. (laughs)
- Well I mean.
You thought that was funny.
- Because anything will be acceptable.
- That's a joke I hope.
- That far in advance.
Actually the reality
is, we're gonna look--
- Experience this hologram of--
- Oh no.
- These elderly people--
- Oh no, you know what's gonna happen.
Because society changes
and societal norms change
and what's acceptable
morally continues to change,
we're gonna look back,
like they will show videos
of us eating testicles like
20 or 30 years from now
and it'll be like can you
believe that we did this
as a society?
The shame.
- Oh gosh.
We'll be in a montage at the
beginning of a documentary
about the decline of--
- It all started when people
started getting entertained
by men eating animal testicles.
And we'll be like, we're right, sorry.
We'll go live in a cave.
- We will grant an interview
for the documentary?
- No no, we'll be in a cave.
We won't speak to anyone.
We'll be publicly shamed.
- Oh and we won't be able to taste--
- We'll be like I'm sorry,
it was a different time.
And they'll be like, we don't care
that it was a different time,
you shouldn't have done it.
- Did you bring sugar and salt?
Okay well I think the conclusion is,
as fascinating as it
is, benign masochism is
and it does apply to certain things.
I do not think it applies to us
because--
- Really, yeah,
in relation to the show,
I completely agree.
- I don't like,
I've never have a hankering
to taste testicle.
- Yeah, me neither, man.
That's the truth.
- That's the truth.
But no judgment if that's you.
All right so there you have it,
a culinary delight spread
before you on a table
of our choosing which
is round and dimly lit.
- Do you have a recommendation for us?
- We gotta throw in a recs
in effect 'cause we try to,
if you hated all of that,
you still stuck around
'cause you want a recommendation.
I'm gonna make this quick but
I'm gonna recommend an app.
It's still in the music-loving genre.
I recommend Genius, it's also a website.
And so if you haven't heard of this,
it's a collective of users who will then
place commentary on lyrics.
Have you ever heard of this?
- No.
- The app is yellow and it's--
- It's called Genius?
- It's called Genius.
And it's--
- Not Genius Scan.
- No.
- Another app.
- That's for receipts.
So yeah, I mean as an
avid partaker in hip-hop,
I'm able to, I need translations.
Like basically Genius is a--
- Oh.
- Is a translation for what--
- To understand the lingo.
- The hell they're talking about.
- Got it.
- In hip-hop these days.
Doesn't mean between all the
mumbling and all of the codes.
They rap in code.
- Right.
- And if this 40 year old
out of touch dude is going
to understand it and fully
appreciate what's happening,
I lean on Genius.
- Wow, that's a good rec.
- Yeah and they have a--
- Is it all lyrics?
Or is it hip-hop in general?
- All lyrics.
Any song that you're
curious about the meaning
and people will up-vote so like the best
user-generated commentary
will kinda rise to the top.
It's got this Wiki vibe
but it's not 100% reliable
but you can kinda tell.
So it definitely helps
shed some light on, I mean,
basically all of hip-hop is code
is what I've learned from the app.
And if you're listening on Spotify,
sometimes on your phone,
they'll have Genius will come up
and add a pop-up video layer.
I learned the back story
about the song Africa.
Because I was just
listening to it on Spotify
and the Genius pop-ups
started coming up on the video
which is pretty cool.
- Oh yeah.
- I just found myself
watching Genius via Spotify
on my phone listening to music.
'Cause I'm into that, so that's the rec.
If you're into that, then go check it out.
And if you think you
know stuff about lyrics,
you can submit stuff.
Again, not a sponsor,
just a rec, have at it.
- Yeah we just give recs, man.
We just give recs, stuff that we like.
- All right.
That's all I got, thanks
for hanging out with us.
Are you hungry?
Go get you something to eat.
- I don't think we talked about anything
that would generate appetite.
- Salt and vinegar almonds.
- Oh yep, those are good.
Don't give 'em to the kids though.
- #EarBiscuits, let us
know about your experience
with benign masochism.
That seemed--
- Or don't.
- Well you know what it is now.
- Yeah yeah yeah, just tell
us how you see gross foods.
- [Link] Yeah, just in the food realm.
- [Rhett] Be more specific, yeah.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)